a lot of interesting news about this
election that is going on you haven't
heard of it we do have a presidential
election Donald Trump if you're waking
up today you might be shocked to hear
that Donald Trump is the Republican
nominee he is not ahead though Hillary
Clinton's national lead to the extent
that the national lead matters given
that we have an electoral college system
in the United States continues to
strengthen Hillary Clinton now leading
in 19 of the most recent 19 poles you
will see at the top of the screen the
Real Clear Politics average where
Clinton's lead has now grown to 7.7
percentage points and in every poll
starting with the bloomberg poll
completed just a couple of days ago all
the way back to an economist yougov poll
taken in the fourth week the end of the
third week beginning of the fourth week
of July the last 19 polls have Hillary
Clinton ahead of Donald Trump now in
some of these she's only up by one like
for example in the right wing leaning
rasmussen reports in some of these she
is up by 15 now let's uh dig more deeply
into this every time I mention this at
the beginning of the week it was 16 of
the last 16 polls now it's 19 of the
last 19 polls every time I mention it
people email me they say David these
poles mean nothing because you're not
including green party candidate Jill
Stein and libertarian candidate Gary
Johnson when you include Stein and
Johnson so say many of the people
emailing me Hillary Clinton's lead
disappears well we have that data and
the reality is that claim is not true as
you can see here in 15 of the last 15
polls Hillary Clinton is still leading
when Gary Johnson and jill stein are
included as options her average lead is
seven point two percentage points here a
difference from when it is only a two
way poll of half a percentage point that
is not really a very big difference as
you can see there when looking at these
numbers I don't question whether Hillary
Clinton is being hurt
by the existence of these third-party
candidates I will in the next segment
actually suggest to you that she is
being helped by these third party
candidacies my question is gary johnson
is currently averaging nine percent will
gary johnson get nine percent of the
vote in november i think the answer
there is no Louis I don't know how you
feel about that when you see these polls
and see Gary Johnson polling 99 percent
seems pretty high but if Donald Trump
keep shooting himself in the foot uh
those people are not going to vote for
Hillary Clinton uh though the most
likely vote for Johnson so I say that
this is somewhat realistic yeah Jill
Stein averaging three point seven
percent of the vote will Jill Stein get
three-point-seven percent of the popular
vote on november eighth uh well that is
uh a more believable number for me might
be something like two percent I actually
think it's quite realistic to think Jill
Stein could end up with three to four
percent uh the the PR round her campaign
has certainly been stronger than we've
seen around a third party candidates at
least at minimum in two thousand eight
and twenty twelve I do not believe Gary
Johnson will end up with nine percent of
the vote nationally but at the same time
what does that really matter we should
really be looking state by state and
that is exactly what I want to do next
with you